I'm dead from work trying to get out of
there and try something new
my name is jr. and I'm an admin clerk at
a nursing home it's pretty boring my
dad's here I'm a little zombie
my name is rocío venado and i am a
personal driver i used to design kids
clothing and now i'm trying to start my
own business doing dog clothing i want
to have the creative freedom to do what
it is that i want with my own business i
haven't pursued a different career
because i'm busy all the time and just
drained from work i would prefer
something that's more helping people out
working with groups today I'm gonna be
shadowing a business owner today I'm
gonna be shy doing someone in a chart ok
guys so today's the day I'm on my way to
buy speed I've never done something like
this I'm just really excited to learn
more I am a creative person so one of
the things that has been really hard for
me is the business aspect this is kind
of where the magic happens this is where
we fulfill all of our orders it's so
cute you know how did you get started we
got started in an apartment in Venice
there were three of us it's just kind of
amazing to see sort of the growth and
the progress I'm really thankful that I
was able to take some super rigorous
business classes but help me get my
business off the ground so how did your
business background help you get started
having a business to Greece that's a
really good foundation and really just
piques your curiosity about a bunch of
different aspects of business I'm
feeling very excited and nervous at the
same time
I'm jr. nice to meet you welcome to
BuzzFeed we're excited to have you here
so how did you end up working in a
charge I took some courses in HR when I
was in college they really helped me get
the foundation for the role that I'm now
in so it's not just work sitting behind
a desk throughout the day I'll have
interviews so what I do is I run down
the stairs run back up the stairs get my
steps in for the day so I just got our
notification that candidate just checked
in in the lobby we have about two
minutes to get downstairs oh hey we're
gonna go on up and take you to your
interview room awesome hey Tessa having
are you taking over your name you know
I'm a video recruiter here at BuzzFeed
so primarily I review incoming
applications a lot of reaching out to
people trying to figure out if they have
the skills to do the position sounds
fine
so why do you want to work with us
that's a business owner a lot of times
you have to wear every single hat and
for me that also involves packing the
boxes I have turned to another meeting
do you want to try okay cool okay like I
literally don't know where this stuff is
that
[Music]
oh this is hard to fit in
hi it was April this event is called
Bruges it's something that we hold every
other month do you want to help set up
yeah let's do it how do I do this though
thank you so much for having me I
learned so much it's actually crazy to
have you here and kind of see how much
we've grown hopefully this is you one
day I hope so too my favorite part of
today was just learning that even though
my business is the creative business I
need to start looking at it through a
business lens my day was awesome today I
was very surprised that it wasn't just
at your desk all day which is what I
didn't want to do after today I feel
like my next step will be to actually
look into college courses I feel
inspired to pursue a career in HR even
though I'm really busy I think I'd be
really beneficial for me to take some
online classes and learn a little more
it's gonna take a lot of work to grow my
business but I'm definitely inspired and
motivated to do so
[Music]